job starts off this hour in Dallas Texas
Joe welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I
appreciate you taking my call I have a
question that kind of dovetails into
your entree leadership section you had a
couple days ago okay you don't mind sure
so I have an aviation company that's
kind of been an a one-man show for many
years but in the last few years it's
been growing and I've been hiring
employees I'm up to four now so it's
pretty small but here's the question how
do I pay for in pay for performance like
some of the areas of my company don't
really have a performance that's hinged
to a number as far as production or
things in this nature how do I go about
paying employees that it could be hinged
to performance without having to open up
my books to them and you know it's
paying off a profit and it's so is there
ever a time where you want to open up
your books to the to your more trusted
employees mmm well we do it several
different ways here obviously where you
you know I would put the I would put the
receptionist on straight Commission if I
can figure out a way I like everybody
having skin in the game you know I love
that you know straight Commission
running my own business my whole life I
don't even know how to think otherwise
but there's a lot of people don't think
that way so a couple things obviously
you can do Commission's where there's
something that's commissionable that's
not really what you're asking about the
second thing you can do as you get a
little bit bigger you're not going to do
it at this size now but I have several
team members here that are trusted and
are seeing the entire set of books but
there are our top echelon of leaders
there's a 15 or 20 of them out of 800 to
give you an idea okay
and they're paid off the bottom line
they're paid as if they were partners
some of them are paid off the bottom
line of the business unit that they run
for instance we might have an SVP of
financial piece and whatever the net
profits of financial piece are that SVP
might get paid off of that hour
operating board members here are paid
like partners they're paid completely
off the bottom line and there's 15 of
them okay
well there's not 15 off the bottom line
but there's 15 operating board members
it's a different type so the Ramsey
family doesn't get paid the same way in
that regard I don't understand your
leftover not every month and every month
we pay it out but but I have a hundred
percent ownership but we just closed the
books and your bonus is based on the
profit of the company that's simple and
we close the books each month you know
by the 15th and we're closing by the 7th
and payout on the 15th of the month
following the that's a pretty
complicated method and I really wouldn't
suggest that with 4 people that'll drive
you nuts ok kind of the more traditional
thing that we do is we have profit
sharing now one of the core values we
have on the back wall of our conference
center when we all meet twice a week and
we talk about this out loud at least
once a month one of the core values of
this organization is we share the
profits I believe in dancing with a girl
they brought you you know and so if
you're in here and you're killing it for
10 years you ought to be sharing in the
profits more than somebody's been here
10 days but if you're in here and you're
killing it we ought to share with you
you know it's that simple I don't have a
desire to make a bazillion dollars and
nobody in this place be paid reasonable
wages plus sharing in the profits so
they're shared and they're sharing in
the profits now what I do there is
before all those other people get their
split and before I get my split those
people off the bottom line and a line
item of expense in their P&L in our P&L
is profit sharing and we just get to the
bottom line of profits and we call it
net profit won and before we get to net
profit o which is the bottom line you
know we take out an emergency fund
percentage its funding retained earnings
we take out a percentage for funding HR
activities we take out a percentage for
profit sharing so in other words every
single month we take a percentage of our
profits and set them aside to share with
our team
and there's guidelines on how that our
sharing with the team we do not tell
them what that percentage is in other
words they don't know what percent I
don't know what percentage of my bottom
line I share with my team they don't
know that but what we do tell them each
month every single month from the stage
in staff meeting is profit share profits
last month that you're going to get a
part of went up seven percent over the
month before and 14 percent over this
time last year okay
which means profits are better so that
that's probably going to mean good news
oh by the way we have 14 new people in
the profit sharing plan because you have
to be here a year before you're in it
okay and and so they've come through
their year and now they're now they're
in the profit sharing plan and so
there's while profits have gone up
there's more people eating at the table
and so the average profit sharing check
this month will go up by 2.4 percent and
we tell them that and so if you know
what you made last month you know you're
gonna get a little bit more this month
or profits are down this month because
we didn't collect this item or we had
this big expense come through on a
server or we're moving to another
building and we're having to pay for all
that crap and it comes out of profits
and so this month profits are down an
average of this and we give them some
indicators relative to where they were
before but they do not know the
percentage because I may adjust the
percentage up or down of our profits
that we allocate and there's no need in
them by trying to back into what the
profitability of the company is that is
not it's a privately held company that's
not a known fact right they've been with
the company a long time or if they have
a particularly valuable because they
order the paid commensurate with the
value to the company you know the
Secretary's paid in less than a-- then a
board member or something this measure
well board members aren't in profit
sharing they're they're eating off the
bottom line anybody that's got a
commissions in our case above a hundred
thousand or if they're in leadership and
they make above two hundred thousand
they're not in profit sharing they're
making plenty of money shut up
you know this is for somebody this is
for somebody who's it down here grunting
it out and I want to be able to share
with the receptionist I wanna be able to
share with the live event producer that
you know that this is making 60k I'd
love for them to have another 10 or 15 K
out of our profits that year and get
them up way above market in terms of
their total earnings but they don't have
a way to do that because they're not on
Commission right and so yeah but what
they do want to pick up a piece of paper
out of the out of the parking lot
because if there's 800 of us dropping a
piece of paper that means we have to
hire another maintenance person and
profits just went down so treat the
freaking place like you own it you're
self employed and you will keep the
profits going up and therefore your
personal wallet will be lined plus you
have the pride of ownership of being
part of a team that it has a sense of
being self-employed so everybody
self-employed we share the profits these
are two of our core values they're both
reflected in that whole system and
that's how we do it and we've changed
that over the years but that's you know
the whole purpose here is a be generous
with the people that are excellent B get
rid of the people that aren't excellent